foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're discussing the
upcoming Harry Potter game Hogwarts
Legacy just recently we were finally
given a definitive release date for the
game February 10 2023 and it seems like
since this announcement was made bought
key games have been rolling out update
after update we were in the dark for so
long and now there's so much to cover I
haven't been covering the game much so
far but rest assured I will be covering
it moving forward today I'm going to be
discussing some new details released in
the game's updated FAQ I'm only going to
be discussing the new information so if
you want the old staff then be sure to
check out my old FAQ video which I'll
link below let's get into it 1. when
will Hogwarts Legacy be available
Hogwarts Legacy will launch on February
10 2023 for Playstation Xbox and PC the
Nintendo switch launch date will be
revealed soon
2. can players choose their Hogwarts
house in Hogwarts Legacy players can
choose their Hogwarts house at the start
of Hogwarts Legacy 3. can players link
their Harry Potter fan club account with
their WB Games account to import their
house in one and two Hogwarts Legacy yes
based on the Harry Potter fan club's
official sorting experience together
with the one ceremony players can bring
their authentic self into the game
linking accounts will also unlock a
beaked skull mask and exclusive house
fanatic robes in game a special set of
house-themed robes so players can
represent their Hogwarts house with
style 4. can players customize their
character in Hogwarts Legacy players can
create the witch or wizard they want to
be in Hogwarts Legacy they can customize
their character the onset of their
Adventure as they progress they'll also
be able to develop their own special
combat style
5. will players establish friendships in
Hogwarts Legacy some students at
Hogwarts will become friends as players
grow these relationships these
schoolmates will become companions who
can accompany players on their Journey
expand their abilities and open up as
players learn their stories 6. will
there be official Hogwarts Legacy
companion books Insight editions is
publishing the art and making of
hogwart's legacy and Scholastic Inc is
publishing Hogwarts Legacy the official
game guide
7. will you see Harry Potter Hermione
Granger or Ron Weasley in the game no
Hogwarts Legacy is set in the 1800s
before the time period of JK Rowling's
Original Stories 8. what are the
dangerous threats in Hogwarts Legacy The
Wizarding World is fought for dangers
including creatures corrupted by Magical
Force Sinister witches and wizards as
well as a possible mounting Goblin
Rebellion 9. does Hogwarts Legacy have a
morality system Hogwarts Legacy does not
have a morality system but players will
encounter various quests and storylines
that will influence the witch or wizard
they choose to become 10. is Hogwarts
Castle explorable in Hogwarts Legacy yes
players will be able to explore a fully
realized Hogwarts Castle where they will
attend classes discover dungeons secret
passageways and challenging puzzles 11.
is quidditch playable in Hogwarts Legacy
Greenwich is not not playable in
Hogwarts Legacy however broom flight for
traversal and to broom race challenges
are part of the game players can also
fly rooms to explore new and familiar
locations surrounding Hogwarts Castle
12. can players ride magical beasts in
Hogwarts Legacy plans can tame Mountain
ride some magical beasts in Hogwarts
Legacy 13. what kinds of classes will
players attend in Hogwarts Legacy
players will attend classes such as
charms defense against the dark arts
herbology and potions where they will
meet their professors learn Dakar spells
grow magical plants brew potions and
more 14. how do players level up in
Hogwarts Legacy in addition to classes
and spells players will have access to a
deep set of upgrades talents and skills
to Aid their progression as a witch or
wizard they can complete challenges
throughout the world to earn experience
and level up their abilities magical
gear can also be upgraded and
specialized to increase offensive and
defensive capabilities in a chosen play
style 15. can players mix and match
spells in Hogwarts Legacy mixing and
matching dozens of spells in Hogwarts
Legacy will let players Define their
combat Style on the path to become the
ultimate duelist 16. what is the room of
requirement the room of requirement is
an important secret of Hogwarts that
helps players customize and grow their
abilities we'll have more details to
share at a later time 17. is there
console exclusive content in Hogwarts
Legacy the haunted hogsmead shop Quest
an eerie mystery Adventure involving
hogsmead shopkeeper Madame Mason will be
available only for PlayStation 5 and
Playstation 4 versions of Hogwarts
Legacy players who complete the haunted
hogsmeade drop Quest and Associated
dungeon will also get exclusive access
to their own shop in hogsmead where they
can sell items in gear at rates better
than anywhere else in game 18. does
Hogwarts Legacy have online or co-op
gameplay Hogwarts Legacy is a single
player experience and does not have
online or co-op gameplay 19. does
Hogwarts Legacy require an internet
connection those who purchase a physical
copy of Hogwarts Legacy will be required
to connect to the internet to install a
day one patch those who purchase the
game digitally will receive the patch
with the initial download
20. will Hogwarts Legacy include
accessibility features Hogwarts Legacy
will include accessibility features
we'll have more details to share at a
later time 21. will Hogwarts Legacy
adhere to Wizarding World law yes while
Hogwarts Legacy is not a direct
adaptation of the books and films the
games are anchored in Wizarding World
lore Avalanche is creating a unique
gaming experience that is inspired by
the magical universe created by JK
Rowling in which players will find new
and unexpected locations characters and
story elements 22. does the game take
place only in Hogwarts Castle Hogwarts
Legacy takes players Beyond Hogwarts to
new and familiar locations including the
Forbidden Forest and hogsmead Village
23. what does Porky mean and why have
you chosen it for this label in the
Harry Potter series a port key is an
object Enchanted to instantly transport
anyone touching it to a specific
location most of the time a port key is
an everyday object that would not draw
the attention of a muggle for portkey
games it symbolizes how games under this
label will transport fans to their own
Adventures inspired by The Wizarding
World
24. our portkey games created with JK
Rowling's approval each experience
offered under Porky games will take
place in The Wizarding World and will be
authentic to it JK Rowling has entrusted
the design and creation of the games to
Warner Bros games and the developers
involved who are collaborating with our
team on all aspects of the games 25.
what is JK Rowling's involvement with
the game is this a new story from JK
Rowling JK Rowling is not involved in
the creation of the game but as creator
of The Wizarding World and one of the
world's greatest storytellers her
extraordinary body of writing is the
foundation of all projects in The
Wizarding World this is not a new story
from JK rolling however we have
collaborated closely with her team on
all aspects of the game to ensure it
remains in line with the magical
experiences fans expect and that's it
for this video I hope you learned
something from this updated game FAQ
stay tuned for more updates in the game
and be sure to subscribe to the channel
to get notified about future videos
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
[Music]